inzwischen kann er auch ganz gut von
seinen eigenen bildern lehnen
diese gemälde würde man sich wohl lieber
nicht übers bett hängen
das abgründige universum von leopold ist
ungemütlich es fasziniert und verstört
idyllisch hingegen ist die landschaft um
neuenburg wo der maler seine motive
sucht
zerfallene gartenhäuschen und schattige
ecken scheren ihm atmosphären die ihn zu
seinen beunruhigenden bildern
inspirieren
für seine foto jagd gilt je
zwielichtiger desto besser
kleine szenen dämmerlicht ist einfacher
zu machen
eine so helle fläche ist viel
schwieriger
unzählige fotografien sammelt hradil für
ein einziges gemälde an oft bleiben sie
lange liegen bis in der kreative blitz
trifft
die fotografien sind nichts als eine
grundlage danach genieße ich es sehr
weit darüber hinaus zu gehen das
wichtigste an der malerei ist für mich
ganz einfach wie man interpretiert was
man sieht
die landschaftsaufnahmen lässt rabbi in
seinen gemälden mit menschen aus seinem
umfeld verschmelzen
der 37 jährige kommt aus einer
künstlerfamilie
nach abstechern in die theaterwelt und
dem abbruch mehrerer kunst studien ist
heute die malerei sei mit ihm für ihn
eine kunst der entschleunigung
die malerei hat etwas behagliches
meine kollegen die videos und
installationen machen erlebe ich dagegen
als äußerst angespannt
bei der malerei ist eben das verhältnis
zur zeit ein ganz anderes es ist eine
art kunsthandwerk man kommt gemütlich in
sein atelier und dann stellt sich bald
eine innere ruhe
habe als traditionell mit öl farben und
in zahllosen schichten bis nach rund
zwei monaten ein gemälde vollendet ist
eine gemächliche kunst hat auch tücken
ich beneide das kino da gibt es die
möglichkeit mit zoom und musik zu
arbeiten
und ich bin gezwungen eine
augenblickliche emotion in einem fixen
bild wieder aufleben zu lassen
leopold rabbou arbeitet auf seine art
filmisch mittels unschärfen schärfen und
farben lenkt er den blick auf details
und
er bringt dynamik in seine werke
eine der großen herausforderung der
malerei ist bewegung zu zeigen damalig
lebendige figuren wir sind einfacher zu
bewegen als bäume
wenn ich eine figur mit drei armen mal
dann ist bewegung gemeint und nicht
zwingend dass diese person 3 1 hat oft
tauchen einzelne körperteile losgelöst
auf eine chaotische weltwahrnehmung
schätzen aus der erinnerung
in der gegenwart sind unsere wahrnehmung
von dinge starke trend aber
in der erinnerung
vermischt sich alles und genau so
funktioniert meine malerei
wer in diesen bildern jedoch nur das
abgründige und schauriger erkennt dem
bleibt wesentliches verborgen
romantik und humor sind bei leopold
stets mit dabei
genug für
sie